good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight in retrospect it's
remarkable just how dishonest how
thoroughly and intentionally dishonest
the media coverage of the written house
story turned out to be
all of it was a lie rittenhouse was not
a white supremacist he was never in a
militia he never crossed state lines
with a firearm the protest in kenosha
was not peaceful it was a riot chaotic
and violent many of the rioters by the
way carried guns rittenhouse was hardly
alone rittenhouse didn't go to kenosha
looking for trouble his father lived
there ridden house himself worked as a
lifeguard in kenosha on august 25th of
last summer rittenhouse went downtown to
stand guard over a car lot here's the
context the night before police in
kenosha had done nothing as the mob
burned businesses including another car
lot all the way to the ground
so the business owner needed kyle
rittenhouse's help he was looking to a
17 year old for help if that gives you
some perspective on how bad things were
and he asked for it
as written house stood there rioters
threatened his life then they attempted
to kill him
in the end written house shot three
attackers as he tried to run to the
safety of the police a number of media
outlets claimed the men written how shot
were black in fact all three were white
and all three had serious criminal
records we could go on again the media
coverage was from beginning to end a
tapestry of lies if you watched the
trial last week you know that
but what about kyle rittenhouse himself
what is he like
apart from his testimony in court few
americans have ever heard his voice
over the next hour we're going to let
kyle rittenhouse speak for himself you
can make up your own mind what you think
but before we start one observation
which you can't resist making
it's hard to ignore the yawning class
divide between kyle rittenhouse and his
many critics in the media rittenhouse
comes from the least privileged sector
of our society during high school he
worked as a janitor and a fry cook to
help support his family last year he got
into college at arizona state and he's
very proud of it in the world kyle
rittenhouse grew up in it is not a given
that kids go to college it's not even
close
during the course of our long
conversation colored now struck us as
bright decent sincere dutiful and
hardworking exactly the kind of person
you'd want many more of in your country
he's not especially political he never
wanted to be the symbol of anything kyle
rittenhouse just wanted to keep violent
lunatics from setting fire to cars
in the america he grew up up in that was
considered virtuous
so if writenow seems a little bewildered
at points during our interview thinking
back over the last year and what
happened to him that's probably why
a lot of the things he assumed were true
about this country turned out not to be
true at all so in that way he speaks for
many of us
here's kyle rittenhouse
so tell me kyle
how you wound up in kenosha that day
well it actually started on august 24th
i was working my job as a lifeguard at
the rec plex in kenosha county and then
the riots were still going on and a
curfew was implied so i went to dominic
black's house and i stayed the night
over there and
saw the videos of the riots and the
arson going on
what did you think of it
it was upsetting because kenosha is my
community
and i just was upset seeing my community
up in flames yeah
i bet you were
um
so you're at your friend's house that
night you've come back from working as a
lifeguard yes
and then
you decide to go in first you're
cleaning up graffiti correct uh yes so
we say the night dogs i say the night
august 24th we wake up in the morning
and we're talking like let's go let's go
help our community let's go see what we
can do and we ended up at ruther central
high school where we were cleaning
graffiti for a couple hours and then we
met with the owners of carsource and
we offered to protect their business
from fires making sure
the rest of the other two properties
didn't get burned down like they did the
night prior
and they agreed
we came back we went back to dominic's
house and
hung out there for a little bit and then
we went
to a
car source to help protect the property
and make sure it didn't set on fire
again
so you get there what do you see
when i get there
i see in the beginning the morning of
ruther central i see just spray paint
everywhere i see smoke coming from the
car source that was
burnt down and it was quite upsetting
because that was somebody's business
that got destroyed yeah
so you said to the people who own the
car lot i want to protect your cars and
they said yes please um i said hey if
you i asked if they needed any help and
they said yes if you can
where were the police
i don't i don't i'm not sure really
because i they have a hard job um for
sure but
i didn't really think they got the
support they needed the national guard
should have been called august 23rd but
the city of kenosha failed
their the community
the governor tony evers failed the
community and there should have been a
lot more resources to help with that
that's for sure
so
you've been criticized for carrying a
firearm into the scene
but it's obvious from the tape that a
lot of people you were not the only one
with a firearm there are rioters with
firearms was that obvious to you yes
so
you saw other people with guns i i did
there was a lot of people um on bo like
there were riders with firearms um i
remember one very simply joshua zaminski
was walking around with a pistol in his
hand all that night with joseph
rosenbaum
where did you first see rosenbaum
the first time i saw rosenbomb was the
first time he threatened to kill me
it was at the corner of the car source
lot that i was at primarily that night
and
i was asking people if they needed
medical and he came up to me and ryan
balch and he said if i catch any of you
mfr's alone i'm going to effing kill you
had you ever seen him before i have not
so you've never seen this guy he walks
up and threatens to kill you out of
nowhere yes
it was it was quite shocking i was like
why would somebody threaten to kill me
i'm just asking if people need help on
both sides i was i was there just to
help anybody that needed and
shockingly the only people i helped that
night were rioters
what kind of sense did you get from
rosenbaum i mean that sounds deranged
when he threatened to kill me i was like
what the heck just happened
i've never nobody's ever threatened to
kill me yeah up until that point
and i was like that's not something you
say to somebody how long after that was
it that he tried to grab your rifle it
was about an hour and a half later and
then there was actually a second time he
said to the group
he said
this is the second time he threatened to
kill everybody he said
i'm gonna i'm gonna effing kill you i'm
gonna cut your hearts out you effing and
words
cut your hearts out yes
did any of the rioters try and calm him
down or stop him
what i noticed is the writers were
trying to like
they were like disassociating with him
because he was like spewing the n-word
around and they just didn't seem to want
to
have anything to deal with them the
rioters
so he comes he tries to grab your rifle
he gets shot
you decide at that point
listen miss remembering you want to go
turn yourself into the police
yes um
after i shoot mr rosenbaum
um
he tried to grab my gun i was running
away there was a gun shot behind me
after i shoot him i run around the car
because i was going to go render first
aid to him
i wasn't able to because then
there was a mob forming and
calling for my execution to get him and
kill him
and that's when i tried to run to the
police line and get to the police
and then i am attacked again
by the by the guy who kicked you by by
jump kick man yes
whose identity we didn't know it turns
out the prosecution knew it and hid it
um yeah um so we found out november 7th
the prosecution
we went into the judge's chambers and
the prosecution said we identified jump
kick man and the prosecution threw a fit
a little bit
they didn't want us to interview him
they were like well he's a victim
and didn't want my investigators or my
attorneys to interview him or ask him
questions they just wanted to do it
private non-recorded and the judge said
no no no it's going to be recorded and
then
a couple hours later they say oh he
asked for immunity and we're not going
to give it to him so we're not going to
be calling him as a witness
yeah well probably didn't want to talk
about his criminal record yeah so did
you so you're running
trying to get to the police lines
you see the mob coming after you let's
execute him they're saying
and then out of nowhere you get dropped
to the ground by the guy who kicks you
in the head did you see him coming i i
did um to backtrack a little bit
actually as i'm running gage gross
scrootz came up to me with his phone and
put it in my face and he said what are
you doing did you just shoot that man
and i told him i'm going to the police
and he said oh okay and ran off and i
kept running to get to the police and
that's when anthony huber
strikes me with the skateboard as i'm
running before i'm on the ground for the
first time and then i'm hit with a rock
by somebody in a white tank top
and that's how i end up on the ground
and i have four people around me from
what i remember
and i
move my firearm in the direction and
they back off with their hands up so i
don't shoot them and then jump kick man
keeps coming and that's when i fired two
shots at jump kick man
wow and he you miss him and he kicks you
yes
then what happens
um
after
um jump kick man is running off
anthony huber comes up and he grabs the
barrel of my gun and then he hits me
with his skateboard holding his trucks
and that's when i shoot him one time
where did he hit you with a skateboard
he hit me in the back of the head um in
the net
the back of the head
towards the neckline
did you think you were going to be
killed at that point i did then what
happens
and then after mr huber attacks me
mr grossgroot puts his hands up
and then i have my rifle pointed in his
direction for about a second and then
once i lower my rifle i noticed that my
ejection port is opened
about an inch and
mr grossgroot said i pulled the charging
handle which never happened i hit the
forward assist to
close the ejection port and that's he
sees me doing that or something and this
time he runs at me and he has his gun
pointed directly at my head did you see
the gun i did
do you think he was going to shoot you i
did
he had it pointed directly at my head
and that's when i shoot him one time and
um
he is no longer a threat to me at that
point because he ran off after i fired
that shot
did you realize you hit him i i didn't
know until later
so then what happens
um there is a person directly in front
of me and i point my my rifle in their
direction and he puts his hands up and
he's not he's backing up
and i then turn around start going to
the police and then i hear shots behind
me and i turn around and briefly raise
my rifle to see if i'm being shot at
and then i realize i can't see who's
shooting at me so then i turn around and
go back to the police car
towards the police line
it's just hearing this it's just hard to
believe this is happening in an american
city
yeah
so then you finally get up
you hear shots you turn to see who's
shooting at you
and then you finally make it to the
police line yes um
once i make it to the
the police cruiser
the police officer says get back get
back get back
one of them has a gun out and the other
has pepper spray pointed at me and i say
hey i just had to shoot somebody i just
had to shoot somebody and then they say
go home and i didn't know this until go
home yeah
the officer said to go home i don't
think he knew what happened or heard me
there's a lot of chaos going on yes um
but apparently he pepper sprayed me um
you can see it in the video but i don't
remember being pepper sprayed by him
so then what happened
um i say okay i go back to the car
source
lot number two we've been referring to
them car source one is the one that got
burnt down
car source two is the one that i was at
primarily the entire night and car
source three is the one where i was
attacked by mr rosenbaum
i go back to car source lot number two
and
i tell everybody there what happened i
said i had to do it i did i was just
attacked i was dizzy i was vomiting i i
couldn't breathe
and i was like we couldn't we i wanted
to turn myself in kenosha to i wanted to
turn myself into the police in kenosha
but i wasn't able to
because they weren't accepting visitors
apparently with the barricades
and the fence up so we ended up turning
myself into the antioch police
department she drove back
across state lines is where now it's
been calling it
you couldn't even turn yourself in
no it was like i i had to go to antioch
police department which to my
understanding is the closest police
department to kenosha
why do you think people were burning car
source what does that have to do with
civil rights
i i don't know i think it was
opportunists taking advantage of the blm
movement i
agree with
the blm movement i agree everybody has a
right to protest and assemble but i do
not agree that people have the right to
burn down i don't i don't appreciate
that people are burning down american
cities
to try to spread their message i think
there's other ways to go around and do
that well i agree with that completely
so you turn yourself into indiana police
what do you think is going to happen at
that point to you
i
didn't know i was quite i was in shock
my head was spinning from being hit in
the head multiple times i had some minor
injuries
i just didn't know i didn't know i was
going to be arrested for defending
myself because everything was on video
but part of the reason i think i was
arrested is because of the mob mentality
and um
they were like oh uh yeah we're just
gonna arrest him even though there was
videos already out showing me being
attacked and having to defend myself
so when was it that you were arrested
i was arrested on august 25th
at around 6am
i was formally arrested without a
criminal complaint being drafted they
didn't know what they were charging me
with yet they were just they just
arrested me at home
at antioch police department
what'd your parents say when you called
them and told them what happened i
didn't call my mom after i saw her and
she was in shock she was like
she wanted to go into hiding and i said
no the right thing to do would be to
turn myself in i didn't do anything
wrong so you knew that from the very
beginning i i knew that
a lot of people are like oh kyle had
time to
meet with his attorneys to come up with
this amazing defensive self-defense no
that's not the case has been 100
self-defense from the beginning and i
didn't know there was 100 cameras i knew
i was but i didn't know i was attacked
and i defended myself
what do you think would have happened to
you if there hadn't been
the amount of video that there is i
can't even imagine i don't think we'd be
sitting here right now having this um
talk tucker
that's for sure
you'd never get out
ridden house knows perfectly well the
only reason he's free is because he can
prove what actually happened thanks to
those videos but it didn't prevent him
from going to jail anyway he did for a
longer period than most people
understand during that time he picked up
a couple of attorneys who said they
would help him
in his view they badly abused him and
his family and their trust
i'll tell you a lot about that in just a
minute and about the prosecutors
also weak programming note we had
cameras behind the scenes throughout
much of this case our tucker carlson
originals documentary called the trial
of kyle premieres in december
[Music]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else